[Music]
forest is with us in
fayetteville north carolina hey forest
how are you
hi dave and christy it's an honor to
talk to you guys youtube
what's up so i'm 25
and i just started my first job after
college
i have no student loans no credit card
debt i have three grand to the bank and
three grand in
single stock and i'm looking to propose
to my significant other and i'm looking
into
moving and living with her and so my
question was
what would you recommend when planning
to purchase
an engagement ring starting to save for
a wedding and that would be two years
from now and
what would be your recommendation for
investment
because i really haven't done any at the
moment
okay cool what do you make
about 60 000 a year would your potential
fiance make
she'll be a high school teacher so
anywhere between 30 and 40 to start out
with
okay so like 100 household income when
you're married right
yes okay well here's a couple of rules
of thumb
uh engagements and weddings are really
important
no kidding dave so uh
and they can both get emotional and
people get stupid
about what they spend on both things so
here's a couple of guidelines for you to
think about
uh since you're going to be saving up
for the wedding
the cheaper the wedding the sooner the
date
that makes sense that makes sense to me
because i heard you say two years
because it was going to take that long
to save the money
when it doesn't take that long to run
down to the justice of the peace by
saturday
this is true i wasn't going to suggest
that i'm just saying
that there's a ratio here that the
cheaper the wedding the faster it occurs
okay
makes sense so uh if uh if you were my
kid i would say don't wait two years
so that you don't move in together
before marriage
don't shack up ahead of time and let's
let's plan a uh a
inexpensive wedding but a nice wedding
and let's get married
in five or six months if you were my kid
that's what i would tell you
okay now then on the on to the
engagement ring
a good rule of thumb the jewelry stores
tell you three months of your income
and that's because they sell jewelry
so a good rule of thumb is one month of
income
maximum so um sweetie's getting a
uh 4 000 3 000 ring max
because that's your take-home pay
which by the way gets you real dadgum
married
sharon's was 1164.
and 39 years later it's still working
good
okay
you with me i think we lost him i think
you scared him
are you gone did i blow did i blow you
out of this out he's like you killed all
my dreams i'm out of here
well you okay what were you thinking of
spending on the ring
i was thinking somewhere between three
and five oh okay
we're on the same we're in the same
ballpark you weren't going to go crazy
because there is no correlation between
the size of the diamond and the success
of the marriage
as a matter of fact there might be an
inverse correlation at some point
okay meaning that you if a large rock is
required the size of a headlight this is
probably not a
not the girl of your dreams but um it's
the girl of your nightmares but anyway
the um
so if that's a requirement so i think
you got you're on track there
and so dude i mean listen like we're
talking ten grand here gets this whole
puppy done and then you move on with
other stuff but in the meantime these
things are top of the line
what do you think christy yeah i think
the only other thing i would question is
for us figure out what your um
what your monthly expenses are and just
make sure that you keep some savings for
your emergency fund when you're making i
don't want you to drain your three
thousand dollars in a savings account
for the ring
and not have any savings this is on top
of your savings
yeah you need to cash out this stock and
stuff so you got six grand to work with
you need about ten
and you so you could be married by
christmas with a ten thousand dollar
wedding and a three thousand dollar ring
if budget's what's holding if budgets
what's holding up the calendar i don't
know if it is but that's what i thought
i heard did i hear that
you said two years very definitively
where'd that two years come from and
don't let him put words in your route
if it's not money tell us you just be
honest for us what are we working with
here why two years
so me personally i want to
be able to actually live with her
a little bit before um
i actually marry her and spend the rest
of my life with her this is not a this
is a woman it's not
shoes you don't have to try them on and
see if they fit
you do what you want to do but um
you know i uh you know the the
actual statistical correlation between
people that shack up before getting
married versus those that don't
the there is very detailed research on
that
and uh this it increases the success
ratio in your marriage
your marriage staying together to not do
that um
and so it there's data on this okay
tons tons of pieces of research on this
and yet there are more people live
together in america today without
marriage than marriage
well and when you when you move in
together it can often be really hard
matt and i moved in together when we got
married
and it was hard so if you're using that
as your lipness test to determine if you
want to
marry her i don't know that's a that's a
good idea
you may change your minds and she could
be the one but it was a hard first six
months because
why do you fold the towels that way i
mean you have some
interesting things wrong with you the
toothpaste put the uh no you don't load
the dishwasher that way
that first year squeeze or roll i'm just
saying it's just bad
yeah but the uh i mean we've been
married 39 years sharon says we had 25
good years of marriage
so i'm just saying that that goes that's
part of the equation
you do what you want to do brother we're
here to help you and love you and tell
you the truth and tell you what we
believe
and uh these are these are this advice
comes from
uh a point of caring and it comes from
uh data data and research and
it comes uh so the average wedding in
america does 28 000 for those of you
listening the average household income
is right about 60. so people are
spending about 50 percent
of their household income on average on
their wedding that's the
average now that's a lot
that's a lot uh it's not to say a 28 000
wedding is
evil um but if you spend over half your
annual income you'd be
over average and that's a double lot
so um we've got lots of our team members
20 somethings all through this building
get married for 10 grand and had some
really nice little weddings
we've had some people spend a lot more
than that including some ramsey girls
but we had the money so there's that
feels like a really big deal before it's
here and then afterwards
it doesn't feel like it's big of a deal
when you're married you got new
priorities we're cleaning out the
closets right now the organizer lady's
there and we're finding all this stuff
from 30 years ago and we're going 20
years ago 10 years ago the kids weddings
our weddings wow